these Egyptian Antiquities are illegal
contraband
among them this portrait traced back to
the first century 16 pieces in total
worth more than four million dollars
it's a celebration uh and it's exciting
to be here with our government Partners
they're now on their way back to the
country from which they were stolen
thanks to an investigation led by the
Antiquities trafficking unit of the
Manhattan District Attorney's Office
Forum just over a decade ago we've
developed this infrastructure where we
can actually share long hard Intel
intelligence and law enforcement
information in order to work our
multinational
investigations at the same speed as the
criminals do
they say illicit art dealers sold the
artifacts to New York's Metropolitan
Museum of Art some as recently as 2015
and the last year they've executed six
search warrants at the Met the largest
and one of the most famous museums in
the United States
Museum officials decline our request for
an interview but say they are working
with law enforcement and fully support
their investigations still some experts
question why it took the met so long to
acknowledge what was right before their
eyes
in the last 20 years standards have
changed for museums when it comes to
verifying the Providence of their
collections
I don't think museums should turn a
blind eye to objects that may be
problematic or could be problematic but
that they should really scrutinize the
objects proactively look through their
records and confirm the veracity of
documents investigators from the
Manhattan District Attorney's Office
continue to work with Federal and
international Partners should the Met
have known what they had in their Halls
yeah I'm not going to comment on any
active investigation other than to say
that the investigation into each of
these separate smuggling networks are
still ongoing already some 1900 pieces
from all over the world valued at more
than 135 million dollars have been
recovered and investigators say they're
not finished yet Kristen salumi Al
Jazeera New York